okay so uh some people are upset because
draymond green did an
interview where he says that uh women
athletes should take more action
instead of paying a complaining about
the pay gap and what he means by that
is um he's all for women getting paid
more and getting paid
what they think they're worth but he
doesn't like that
he hears a lot of these female athletes
coming out and talking about how
they need to get paid and still play and
they don't
take advantage same thing with the ufc
exact same exit to a t i'm with draymond
green on this
complain complain yet you still
participate like let's say
you were you were you're upset about
your pay but you still
showed up and did the show every day
yeah i'm not gonna do i'm gonna keep him
yeah
because it's like yeah because you're
not going to do [ __ ] because it's like
how serious are you about it [ __ ]
so you're not going to complain on every
platforming complaint yet you still play
every day
yeah you're still playing or you're
still doing the podcast every day so
people are mad at draymond
i think a lot of people like saw the
headline of like oh he thinks women are
complaining about the pay gap and they
took that out of context
for him he's saying more like in this
day and age there are so many companies
out here
trying to look like they're inclusive
saying like oh we believe that women
should get paid more this and that like
tell those companies to put their money
where their mouth is exploit them trying
to
look good in the public without like
them actually oh god
so all they saw was taking advantage of
people saying like oh we think women
should get paid more like if
uh yeah he's right nike says women
should get paid more the
pay gap the pay gap is [ __ ] up
meanwhile like call nike out on it and
say like they'll
pay us more yeah they're nike then pay
your athletes the same that you pay
drake and jordan
that's what draymond's saying he's not
saying that women he's absolutely
when it comes down to black and white
bottom dollar they're gonna go well
the reason why we don't pay them as much
because they don't bring the same
numbers
but it's pretty easy to figure out wma
we've seen this before it doesn't bring
anywhere near the viewership men's do
so if i'm a sponsor i'm not paying wnba
the same i'm paying mba
and it's not a female male thing it's
just that organization doesn't bring as
much as this organization
this organization just has to be would
you guys do you think that's because of
the lack of pay
no no no one's watching america tells
you what's popping
the world tells you what's popping no
one's paying attention to it so if
you're an advertiser why would you pay
the same price for something that's like
in the same viewership but it's i mean
it's
i never see it it's very black and white
same as this so if someone came to this
show was like hey
we'll give you a million dollars and
then another show that only goes
get the thousand downloads i think like
well
because we're three women we should be
the same as we should get paid the same
as chappelle malek and brendan
that advertising like well no they get
more views yeah but we're women
okay you don't get the same amount of
views yeah so why why would we pay this
much
yeah because we're women that we don't
care yeah we're just trying to sell
product yeah i tried
yeah i'm just trying to understand yeah
i just yeah i'm just trying to
understand it like we're
should like increase their pay you know
because sponsors aren't going to pay
this thing
well i mean that's the union that's like
the wnba union why they have an
association that you got the bargain
agreement with these owners to have more
money
so also now why don't the owners have
more money because they're not selling
tickets they're not getting
uh viewership on the their network but
how heavy are they
how heavy are they promoted though
they're promoting is that is that like
fair
it's not it's not fair to ask mike green
actually talks about that a little bit
too he says
that he thinks a big problem with women
not getting paid enough
is that there isn't really like a
promotion
where you hear about these females
that's that's what that's what i'm
saying
yeah and he says that there are a lot of
like we think if they put the same
american dollars behind women's wnba
compared to men's nba get the same
viewership
no it's not out of your [ __ ] i don't
think you get the same but it'd probably
go up it increases
don't think so because everyone's aware
of the wnba yeah but we don't know when
they're playing when's that time you
watch the game i haven't watched the
game and you think it's just because you
don't know when it's airing no yeah
exactly
you know the games come on early in the
morning at like 10 a.m when we wake up
like oh
it's a game on the wnba player before
the the prime time games
so again on espn if they advertise now
yeah but i wouldn't
that's that's what i'm saying like it
like i don't watch football but i know
i know who some football players are i i
mean i only know brittany greiner and
taurasi
from www.candice parker
and i don't you you know basketball
better than i do you know
she does there's some big names there
but look at look at the ufc
you know they they market the [ __ ] out
of their female champions
now do they get marketed the same as say
conor no why is that because connor
brings in more pay-per-views
okay so someone like amanda nunes
is she's on the speed of champ not like
the best we've ever seen
she she rolling though i'm sure she does
well
doesn't do nearly as well as the top 10
males
oh that's a great example christian
shields uh the one group she calling
herself
the other boxers issues she called out
leila ali
that's a mega fight that's not a mega
fight in women's
that's not a mega fighter and women's i
don't know what world what woke world
you're living in that's not a mega fight
they try to push it how many people are
going to watch it that's what i'm that
was my point that's my point
they're going to watch it they want to
make they want and layla lee hasn't
fought in how long
yeah but again that she wants some she
said well i'll fight her for like what
10 mil
and it was like we're not giving you
that time who's going to pay that
exactly that's what they said
but again my thing is if if to the wnba
you can't have
if you don't like it you can't set it up
because you're not playing money to go
you don't have enough money to go on
strike
all right fishing complaining interviews
what's the highest paid
wnba player highest paid wnba
yeah like i guess like right now i think
they're uh what is like
the average salary for like a wnba
player i guess that's my question
hundred thousand one hundred thousand
two hundred thousand right yeah go on a
boner
don't wanna bonner or see two hundred
thousand yeah
she she plays for the she makes 200 a
year
yeah for the season or sorry first
season yeah
that's how that oh okay candace parker
was the highest uh
paid athlete wnba player
skyler diggins yeah she's not she'll be
yeah she's dope she's hot
beautiful so the highest around two
hundred thousand
yeah in the but but again the top three
i know two of those
but again the the the reason why kyrie
irving and durant and lebron and payton
were look at the merch sales
yeah have you seen a brittany grinder
who have you seen anyone rocking a
britney grinder jersey
what's last time in arizona no you
haven't
you're right thank you thank you
thank you i like the effort though
but again it's just number thing because
if lebron wasn't selling jerseys and
britney was
she would get all the money she would
get all the money like the public let
you know
you know yeah you don't even see those
women basketball jerseys
i've never seen one i was about to say
well you know what i would [ __ ] buy
one and wear it on a [ __ ] show
why are you saying huh are you serious
would that be weird
no i'm just that'd be cool
yeah but they don't even sell it what do
you think you can get it shopping
oh nike doctor oh okay wait where
hundred bucks
okay 100 bucks that's kind of like a
little price that's
kind of steep 100 bucks what for that
jersey for a brittany grinder jersey
they get all those things that's worth a
hundred dollars
do they have a size of men that's the
great that's the question i'm sure
okay
why is that why the logo has to be like
18 has to be on the jersey
like somebody get money oh
okay all right all right what else you
guys got
salute to them women mm-hmm how about
that when i get off stage at the lab
factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son